hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is a
spring 2014 edition in this edition are
articles on important changes to council
tax local and European elections Small
Business Saturday bring on the prom tips
to secure your home freecycle tagging
and much more but we'll begin with news
of a very special award MBA award for
Lucy Rochford athlete Lucy Hodges has
been awarded the MBE for services to
blind sailing in the Queens New Year's
Honours List Lucy said 2013 was a great
year for the charity blind sailing
winning the blind worlds and increasing
participation on the water it was such a
shock to receive an MBA in the New
Year's Honours I was overwhelmed I see
this as an honor to all that support the
charity and be from the sighted
volunteers to funders being a sailor and
the Commodore of blind sailing makes it
a busy time but with the support and
backing I received it comes together
rochford District Council and local
shops have offered me great support and
the success of the show with gold at the
world's I still I still have a smile on
my face when I hear Lucy Hodges MBE
amongst numerous awards Lucy was Essex
Paralympic hopeful in 2009 and the
Rochford district sports personality of
the year in 2010 Lucy's dream was always
to win the world and international blind
sailing championships despite being
selected for the last four world
championships winning two silvers and
two bronze medals selection wasn't
guaranteed and Lucy fought hard secure
her place for the 2013 event in Japan
the MPA is deserved recognition for what
lucy has achieved both on and off the
water section 2 community lottery boast
for services Rockford and rayleigh
Citizens Advice Bureau in partnership
with castlepoint Citizens Advice Bureau
three other local organizations have
secured funding from the big lottery
fund advice services transition fund
until August 2015 to enhance the current
advice services for residents in both
Rochford district and castle point Boro
they are currently working hard on the
project advice 360 which is expanding
and developing advice services in these
areas to ensure that benefits debt
housing and employment advice are
seamlessly integrated into their
existing services if you're interested
in finding out about volunteering or are
part of a local support organization
would like to know more about the
project please contact 0787 6470 one
double o reeling from Christmas debt and
bills in 2014 it is once the excitement
of Christmas and the new year
celebrations have ended that people
begin to struggle with making ends meet
particularly when rent or mortgage
payments are due and credit cards bills
arrive money issues can be a major worry
for anyone Citizens Advice can help you
deal with creditors and help you to deal
with your debts the Citizens Advice
website is WWE Divas guide or qk it has
pages dedicated to tackling debt and
dealing with creditors or alternatively
contact your local citizens advice
bureau in rochford and rayleigh citizens
advice tips for dealing with debt sort
out how much you owe work out which are
the most urgent debts and how much you
have to pay these off deal with the most
urgent debts as a matter of priority
look at your options for dealing with
the less urgent debts and work out how
to pay them off after you have cleared
the most to urgent debts contact your
creditors and make arrangements to pay
back what you owe work out your options
if you don't have enough money to pay
off all your debts seek help from your
nearest citizens Vice Bureau or other
free advice agency to start dealing with
your debt the opening times of the
rayleigh and rockford advice bureaus and
their addresses are Rochford office back
lane rochford SS 41 a why
choose the end Thursday 10 a.m. till 2pm
the rayleigh office is at the civic
sweet hot kero rail ESS 680 be monday
thursday and friday ten a.m. to 2pm do
you need grant funding but don't know
where to start do you know that rayleigh
Rochford and district association for
voluntary service ravs has a dedicated
funding officer who could help you
identify potential funding for your
charity or project shelley hall the
funding officer has access to software
called grant finder from where a report
that will deep detail potentially
suitable funding bodies can be provided
the service also includes support with
the application forms and the paperwork
that may be required as evidence along
with the application to potential
funding bodies ravs has supported a
number of local voluntary and community
groups within the Rockford district over
the past 12 months with over 65,000
pounds being secured to enable them to
continue their good work in the
community you can apply for funding for
capital items such as new computer new
buildings and improvements equipment of
any kind and much more you can also
apply for funding to deliver your
service and this can include for example
salary costs and volunteer expenses and
again much more revs will be there to
guide you through the process ravs
offers a funding advice drop in every
tuesday from 930 to 1230 no appointments
necessary please feel free to come along
and discuss your organization's funding
needs and project ideas if you'd like to
meet at a convenient time that suits you
then please contact shelly hall on 0 1 2
68 double 727 96 to make an appointment
we look forward to hearing from you
learn computer basics the rayleigh
Rochford and district association for
voluntary services revs would like to
tell you about computer access training
that is available for anyone who is over
25 years of age
and living in rochford district council
area if you have little or no experience
of computers you can learn the basics of
many different types of software how to
email friends and family and how to
browse the internet and much much more
there are 25 week in formal courses to
our sessions running one after the other
these are course one keeping in contact
is the place to start if you are an
absolute beginner course to getting more
from computing if you want to learn more
you can just take course 1 or course too
but if you wish to do both please take
course one first training is also
available for people in their own homes
who have mobility or access problems
please note this is not a course but is
designed to assist with a difficulty on
a specific aspect it is not necessary to
have attended any course but it is aimed
at helping with any part of the project
there are small fees for the computer
course and home visits for more details
please contact revs on 0126 877 to 796
or you can visit their website at
www.adr.org trail beat competition from
across the east of england to win yet
another towns alive 2013 award the art
trail was declared the overall East Zone
winner this follows another award
earlier this year as the environment and
culture category winner the awards
recognise inspirational ideas and
projects that other towns and
neighborhoods can replicate according to
action for market towns who run the
town's alive 2013 Awards the judges
commented that the Rochford arts trail
combines artists creativity with a
level-headed approach to marketing a
town and measuring the benefits
importantly to this annual event keeps
growing and adding new twists so that
visitors come back for more
awards were for last year's event that
ran from 27th of October to the third of
November and until this year was the
biggest ever with more artists and
businesses being part of free arts
activities workshops and hosting
colorful and creative window displays
the rockford art trail is now an
established event on the district's
cultural calendar and is organized by
Rochford district council working in
partnership with Essex adult community
learning Rochford and open arts the
trail is supported by virgin active its
curtain up on a popular program of
Family Theater as the latest shows on
offer have been announced throughout the
autumn and winter professional shows for
family audiences have been selling out
at the mill arts & Events Center and due
to popularity organizers have announced
shows up until the end of a year one
local parents said we're really enjoying
the shows and really pleased they're
continuing we look forward to attending
lots more all performances are at two pn
and the dates are as follows oshima and
the sea on Sunday the 11th of May how
high sunday the 15th of jun xu baby
sunday the 13th of july that's also at
11am you're not my friend anymore sunday
the twenty-first of sep tember fireside
tales with grandad sunday the twelve of
october and the magic porridge pot
sunday the ninth of november tickets go
on sale on the first of april 2014 and
cost just three pounds fifty each to
book please call Rochford district
councils customer services team on 0 1
702 3 18 19 1 full details of all the
shows are available by visiting w wh 0
govt UK or emailing arts at Rochford
gavotte UK windmill tourism award
rayleigh windmill has a gain achieved
the accreditation of quality assured
visitor attraction from visit England
this is the fourth year in a row that
the windmill has received this
recognition visit England is a national
body that assesses visitor attractions
throughout the country the report
praised the warm welcome offered by the
volunteers as well as their enthusiasm
and knowledge it went on to say that the
volunteer staff were excellent and a
credit to the organization they were
attentive to both younger and older
visitors and provided a warm welcome and
interesting insight into the attraction
and the area this is fantastic news the
rayleigh windmill is one of the
district's most iconic landmarks and
we're all very proud of it to yet again
have industry recognition shows not only
residents but prospective visitors to
the district that this is an attraction
that is well worth a visit the windmill
reopening and exhibition times are Sundy
the 30th of march through and including
sep tember opening times are wednesday
from ten o'clock to one o'clock and
saturdays and sundays from one o'clock
to four o'clock also look out for the
special events throughout the year the
windmill is also hosting various
exhibitions this season including
exhibitions to mark the hundredth
anniversary of the outbreak of World War
one more information is available on our
website including dates when the
windmill is closed for private functions
a call for volunteers the windmill would
not be as successful or popular as it is
today without the support and generosity
of its volunteers we are always looking
for more people to become involved in
the windmill for more information on
events at the windmill and for details
on how to get involved in volunteering
at the windmill please contact us
weddings the beautiful rayleigh windmill
is over 200 years old and is great too
listed it is a unique and intimate venue
for your civil wedding civil partnership
naming ceremony or renewal of vows with
seating for up to 20 guests for more
information about the above please
contact the leisure team for details
phone o 17025 463
66 or email leisure at Rochford gov UK
allocations plan adopted rochford
District Council's recently adopted
allocations document sets out details of
the sites to be developed across the
district over the next 15 years for
housing employment and other uses the
final draft of the allocations document
was approved that a full council meeting
on Tuesday the twenty-fifth of February
along with the hockley area action plan
the allocations document includes maps
and diagrams of how land in the district
will be used whether that is for
residential use employment use or
education use open spaces or
environmentally protected areas for
example the allocation of land does not
automatically grant consent for the land
in question to be developed it is the
council view that these sites are the
most suitable for development those
wishing to develop the land will still
be required to make a planning
application to the council and for it to
be granted permission before they can
develop the land the UNAC asians plan
forms part of what is known as the
development plan for the district and
planning decisions should be made in
accordance with the development plan as
such what is in the allocations planned
will affect what gets built and where to
view these documents visit w WAW k where
you can also view the council's area
action plans for rockford and rayleigh
or phone 0170 2546 366 help our animal
charities spare a thought for the local
animal charities that need your help
acres way kennels are asking for any
donations that you're able to make for
the abandoned dogs they look after the
kennels would be more than grateful for
any monetary donations to help pay for
the dog's health care and also any dog
food or unwanted towels unfortunately
duvets or pillows can't be accepted as
these make a mess if the dogs chew them
please send any donations two acres way
kennels great virtues Road thundersley
essex SS 73 n ii and rayleigh cats
protection are looking for people who
might want to re-home or foster a cat so
they can free up space to take more
strays in to get fed vet checked and
generally cared for if you're interested
in fostering or rehoming one of their
cats either phone 0126 8750 831 or visit
www cats Riley org UK the animal welfare
charter can be viewed on the council's
website or for a hard copy contact
customer services on 0 1 702 3181 double
one changes the council tax from the
first of april 2014 properties with
annex with effect from the first of
april 2014 a fifty percent discount may
be available on the council tax bill for
an annex if the occupier of the annex is
related to the occupier of the main
house conditions apply if you think this
change applies to you contact us for
more information properties that are
unoccupied with effect from the first of
april 2014 the following changes will
apply to council tax charges in respect
of unoccupied properties if a property
is unoccupied because it needs or is
having major repairs or structural
alterations a fifty percent discount
will be applied for a maximum of twelve
months if a property is unoccupied and
substantially unfurnished a hundred
percent discount will be applied for a
maximum of one month this discount will
be restricted to a maximum of two wards
in any financial year if a property is
unoccupied and substantially unfurnished
for a period of more than two years a
50-percent premium will be applied and
charged in addition to the hundred
percent council tax charge if a property
is unoccupied and furnished no discounts
will apply if you would like more
information or advice about any of these
changes please visit our
site on our website you can find out
about the following online services how
to pay what to do if you are moving
discount and exemptions council tax
support property bandings charges and
appeals how to contact us phone 0170
2318 197 or 0 1 702 318 198 or visit our
website www k / council tax paperless
billing to help save money and protect
the environment switch and receive your
council tax bill through your inbox not
your letterbox simply visit w hv govt UK
/ paperless billing fill in the form
click Submit and we will do the rest for
you change is to bailiff fees from the
6th of april 2014 in the law relating to
bailiffs and the fees they can charge
will be changing bailiffs will be known
as enforcement agents the council can
send a case of unpaid council tax or
business rates to an enforcement agent
once the court order has been obtained
if no payment arrangement has been
reached once the case has been passed to
the enforcement agent they will charge
the customer 75 pounds this is to cover
their initial work in what will be
called the compliance stage the
enforcement agent will attempt to reach
the customer by phone email or letter to
arrange payment if they can't collect
the outstanding balance at the
compliance stage the debt will move to
enforcement stage where the fees that
can be charged will be 235 pounds this
stage will involve visits to a property
to collect the debt and or remove goods
if goods are removed for sale a further
fee of 110 pounds will be charged if you
get into difficulty paying your council
tax or business rates please contact the
council at the earliest opportunity we
will try to reach a suitable payment
arrangement with you this may prevent
the day
to being passed to the enforcement agent
and the additional fees being in code
for further information or to discuss
any outstanding council tax or business
rates please contact the council's
recovery team on 0170 2318 019 local and
european elections the elections are set
to take place on thursday at the twenty
second of May 2014 elections for the
European Parliament take place every
five years and the last election was in
june 2009 there are 12 electoral regions
in the United Kingdom and Rockford
belongs to the eastern region which is
represented by seven members of the
European Parliament elections to
Rochford District Council will take
place on the same day the council
consists of 39 wards and a third of the
seats are up for election elections are
due to take place in the following
Ward's down all and laureth foul ness
and great wakering Grange Hawk well
north or south hawk well west hockley
central hullbridge raley central
Rochford Trinity Wheatley and white
house the parish councils of raw earth
and Rochford are also up for election
make sure you're on the electra register
or you will not be able to vote in the
upcoming elections the deadline for
registering to vote is the six of May
for more information on the elections
and how to register to vote or to apply
for a postal vote visit w WR govt UK
forward slash elections or you can
contact the election office on 0 1 702
3181 h7 or email elections at Rochford
gov UK and don't forget to vote by
signing up for our free free service the
election alarm clock the election alarm
clock is a convenient way to keep up to
date with all the information regarding
upcoming elections by signing up to the
alarm clock you will be alerted to
upcoming elections
and how to register for elections when
and how you can vote and where you can
vote to sign up for this service visit w
WH foods gov UK forward slash election
alarm clock fill in your details as
requested and click Submit that's it
once you've done this you will start to
receive election alerts and there's lots
more information on our website such as
the current composition of Rochford
district council how to become a
counselor how you can register to vote
application forms for proxy and postal
voting and the latest and past election
results don't forget elections on the
twenty-second of May 2014 small
businesses Saturday was hailed a success
the district small businesses showcased
the entra preneur 'i'll nature and
unique boutique offering that populates
the towns and high streets by joining
the celebrations for small business
saturday on one of the busiest shopping
days of the year 7th of december last
year over 120 small businesses in the
Rochford district took part in small
business saturday by decorating their
offices and shops providing special
discounts to customers and giving away
prizes rochford District Council worked
in partnership with hotly Parish Council
raley Town Council rochford parish
council chambers of trade and the local
small businesses community to provide
various activities and events and
encourage the public to support their
local small businesses rochford
districts councils portfolio holder for
economic development regeneration
business liaison and tourism councillor
Mike steptoe said small business
saturday was a huge success for our
district and I would like to thank all
of our partners for making it so
successful small businesses have
embraced the ethos of the national
campaign and I hope that customers will
continue to return to their local small
businesses the district has a very
intrapreneurial character and unique
offering
and it's great to see this being
celebrated we'll be taking part in this
event in 2014 along with independence
day on the fourth of July so if you
would like to get involved or have any
suggestions or ideas then do get in
touch the events were managed by shop at
my local a local initiative that
encourages shoppers and businesses to
keep trade local to stay up to date with
all the activities and to join the shop
at my local scheme you can follow the
campaign on WWF facebook.com slash shop
at my local or on the website www cool
calm business is making the most of
complimentary seminars rotifer District
Council has led the way in providing
local businesses with a series of free
business seminars by teaming with Pro
actions Business Improvement Essex
limited the seminars have proved so
successful that other local authorities
have followed suit by offering Pro
actions business seminars the seminars
are aimed at leaders of small to medium
sized businesses and they give business
leaders a fantastic level of advice and
help on ways to make positive changes to
their businesses the lead speaker is
Colleen blaw director of pro actions
Business Improvement Essex limited colin
has been involved in most aspects of
banking over 34 years including the role
of local bank manager starting up a
standalone internet bank credit and risk
assessment business development and
significant work in the small to medium
sized business market in addition to
sales and risk management for a team of
financial advisors rotifer District
Council has now joined forces with
Castle Point Borough Council to provide
a larger scope of attendees so that
businesses can make the most of the
networking opportunity members of our
local business community attended the
most recent seminar on marketing social
media and websites which was held on
Wednesday the fifteenth of January
marketing is easy to get wrong waste
money on and get frustrated with this
session focused on understanding
importance of marketing how to achieve
more for less spend how to use social
media effectively avoiding the pitfalls
and majoring on the benefits feedback
has continued to be positive and the
economic development unit have finalized
the program of seminars for 2014-15 for
more information please contact the
economic development unit on 0 1 702 318
0 60 or via email business at Rochford
guru k out and about on some george's
day there's a coffee morning organized
by hopland hawk well wi and hockley
village WI it's at the hotline hawk well
55-plus center in the car park behind
hockley library South End Road it will
be on Saturday the 26th of April between
10am and 12 noon enjoy a friendly chatty
morning there's a table top sale and a
raffle it will cost one pound fifty for
a cup of coffee or tea and a cake clubs
and groups the mega center Rayleigh
strengthening families courses special
care babies group weekly special needs
activity sessions dads and kids club at
the mega center rayleigh seven brook
road rayleigh SS 67 UT for details of
any of the activities contact the Center
for details the telephone number is 0 1
2 6 8 double 791 double O you can email
Jan bow our spell out for you j EI n ba
ugh at mega center rail each coat UK and
the website is w WM egga center riley co
uk heart beeps of baby and toddler music
sessions at the wishing world children's
center in rockford these are on tuesdays
from the twenty first of January it's
three pounds fifty per session to be
paid a session in advance booking is a
sin
sure so contact the Children's Center
directly on Oh 17025 for 1460 the
contact for this is heart beeps email
Lorraine at heart beeps com WWE
heartbeats comm arts sports and leisure
dates for your diary the seventh to the
twentieth of April Easter holiday
activities tenth and eleventh of May
National Mills open weekend 26th to the
30th of May wits and holiday activities
seventh of June Wildwood stay 23rd of
July to the 29th of August summer
holiday activities during August summer
sports festival 11th to the 14th of sep
tember heritage open days 18th to the
27th of sep tember Rochford art trail 27
to the 31st of October October half-term
holiday activities sixth of November
Rochford and Castle Point sports award
and there is a disability disability
sports festival but the date is yet to
be confirmed horticultural society
hockley and district trading heart
behind hawk or village hall is free
parking it's opening every sunday from
the second of every to the 26th of
October 2014 offering compost grow bags
and all sorts of fertilizer plus
friendly advice on gardening membership
his three pound per family per year fcas
tractor-trailer tour of fairness island
on the 11th of june and the 25th of june
at 630pm this is 17 pounds per person
limited spaces are available contact
karen Kearsley 0170 2318 143 or karen
Kearsley at Rochford gov you k
counseling committee meetings all
meetings will take place at the civic
sweet to hockey road Railly
680 be starting at seven thirty p.m. the
executive on Wednesday the second of
april standards committee first in the
third of april review committee choose
to the eighth of april full council
Tuesday the 15th of april and
development committee first in the
seventeenth of april for information
contact member services on 0 1 702 318
140 if you're going to promote an event
in the Rochford district please email
details to communications at Rochford
gov you k to consider for inclusion
please note that although events are
checked before going to press they are
subject to change we recommend you visit
our website at www k or contact the
organizers to check before going to an
event if you've got an event we can put
it on our DM online visit www k the
inclusion of any companies advertising
in any of our publications on our
website or in our buildings should not
be seen as an endorsement of that
company's products events and/or
services nor is it a select list of
businesses that we use we reserve the
right to refuse entirely at our own
discretion to publish an advertisement
or to withdraw the advertisements
without notice get smart with your
sharps we're urging residents to ensure
that medical waste is not placed into
your grey curbside recyclables bin this
waste is not recyclable and could
contaminate other material causing
problems at our recycling facility the
recycling process includes operatives
hand sorting material needles could harm
the staff involved and potentially
spread disease medical waste includes
sharps boxes full or empty needles or
syringes incontinence waste or nappies
bandages plasters and dressings needles
should be disposed of into a sharps box
and boxes should be either taken to your
local health center details can be found
at the establishment which provided the
box to you it
advisable to find out your local
disposal point when issued with us shops
with a sharps box rochford District
Council is the top recycling Authority
in the country and we need your help to
keep it that way for a full list of what
goes into which bin please see www k
/recycling or contact customer services
for reciting information on 0 1 702 3181
double one bright sparks recycle
thinking of having a spring clean
remember that old broken or unwanted
small electrical item that can be
recycled at many of our recycling bank
sites the small electrical items
accepted include mobile phones kettles
and toasters electrical personal care
examples hair dryers straighteners and
shavers cables and chargers DIY & garden
electrical equipment such as power tools
please do not bring large electrical
goods including fridges and freezers TVs
or any item with the screen example a
computer monitor light bulbs or
fluorescent tubes and batteries for full
details of recycling banks near you
visit w hv govt UK / recycling or
contact customer services to find out
where your nearest bank is on 0 1 702
318 111 bags of style if your wardrobe
needs to sort out please place any clean
good quality reusable clothing into blue
bags supplied by essex textiles things
couldn't be easier simply fill up your
bag with your unwanted textiles and put
them out for collection next to your
grey recyclables bin alternatively a
one-off collection can be arranged for
more information phone essex tectiles on
oh-eight-hundred 787 9071 Rochford
district residents using the recycling
center at stop road south
and may be charged to use the facilities
help us drive down litter car litter is
a national problem carletta makes Road
sighs look dirty and can blow into open
spaces and residential properties our
street cleansing contractor co uk spend
more than 2,000 hours and collect 1,300
tons of litter from the streets of
Rochford district every year that's the
equivalent of 87 elephants throwing
litter is also very dangerous litter
could hit another road user potentially
causing an accident litter can be a
cigarette butt or piece of chewing gum
or bag of rubbish drivers seem to throw
litter from their cars can be reported
traced and could be issued with a
75-pound fixed penalty notice an old
carrier bag can be used to store rubbish
in your vehicle and it can then be
deposited into a bin when stationary
there are over 300 litter bins
throughout the district the bins offer a
convenient way for residents to dispose
of their waste when on the go the
majority of these are used correctly
however some litter bins are being
misused sacks of household or business
waste are being deposited in and around
her litter bins causing the bin to be
full and restricting the use for other
residents this is classed as fly-tipping
an investigation into the origins of the
waste will be carried out which could
lead to prosecution for details of how
to deal with excess household waste or
business waste phone recycling on 0170
2318 one double one or e-mail recycling
at Rochford gavotte UK calling all dog
owners are you being responsible it is
illegal to leave your dog's feces lying
around in a public area if a dog is in
your care for any length of time it is
your responsibility to clean up its mess
council officers regularly patrol the
district and irresponsible dog owners
could be issued with a 75-pound fixed
penalty notice for not picking up after
their dogs
dog fouling is unsightly unpleasant and
occur and can occasionally lead to
toxocariasis in humans which can cause
serious illness and even blindness
residents are also urged to dispose of
bagged feces correctly by placing them
into the nearest bin this can be a
general litter bin or dog waste bin bags
left on fences or trees will be treated
in the same way as not picking up the
feces to report a street seem problem
online w wh the govt UK / street scene
or you can email customer services at
Rochford gov UK or phone 0170 2318 111
recycle for essex what more can i do
make full use of your local recycling
centers can be rode on canvey island ss8
oqx Ferris Road south woodham ferrers
transferred cm3 5z a castle road
rayleigh ss6 7qf for more information on
opening times and what you can take
visit essex gov k 4 / recycling centers
or call 0845 6037 625 did you know that
you can take these following items to
your local recycling center for reuse or
recycling electrical appliances and
electronic equipment fluorescent tubes
and low-energy light bulbs batteries all
household and car batteries can be
recycled cooking oil pour unwanted
cooking oil into a sealed container such
as a plastic drinks bottle and place in
the bin provided wood and timber all
types of wood including treated wood can
be recycled discover the joy of reuse
for your handy guide to reuse and how to
pass on and discover good quality used
items visit recycle for Essex co uk
cloth nappies you could save 500 pounds
by using cloth nappies instead of
disposables
visit the recycle for essex website for
more information including our refund
offer recycle for essex co uk reduce
food waste reducing your food waste
could save an average family with
children 700 pounds a year find out
about planning your meals using
leftovers storage and much more visit
the love food hate waste website for
more information love food hate waste
calm compost garden waste composting is
a great way to reduce your garden waste
unproduced free nutritious soil improver
in the process it also helps the
environment by reducing vehicle
movements to purchase a reduced price
compost bin visit recycle for essex co
uk or call 08 double 457 14 double for
for inspirational food and garden lovers
wanted join the award-winning waste
Buster's volunteer team and be a waste
reduction hero in your community to find
out more or book your place please
contact waste Buster's volunteer
coordinator at waste Buster's at essex
gov you k or phone Oh double 77 1898 13
tone keep up to date with the latest
news sign up to receive our online
magazine at recycle for essex co uk
follow recycle for essex on facebook the
one stop shop for all your recycling
needs you can contact us waste
management at essex gov you k 0845 603
7625 destructive power of floods the
Environment Agency has a campaign to
make us aware of the destructive power
of floods a fact that has been
demonstrated to many both in our
district and in the country as a whole
by the recent storms and the surge tired
the message is for us to be prepared so
here are a few steps to follow be warned
the daily weather forecasts give details
of severe weather and flood risk with
more information available
the Met Office and environment agency
websites if your property is
particularly at risk you can receive
more specific warnings through the
Environment Agency flood line service
find out if you're in a flood risk area
on their website protect your home if
your home is at risk take measures to
protect it from flood water sandbags are
a poor defense look at proper flood
defence products that are effective and
easy to use advice can be obtained
through the flood forum in particular
through their blue pages and independent
directory of products and services take
action if you think water is about to
enter your property move valuable items
upstairs or to a higher level ensure you
have access to essential medicines if
you think you may have to leave your
property prepare an overnight bag and
have suitable clothing ready be insured
have details of your insurance policy
with you your company will be able to
assist you if you're flooded budget
consultation the following areas were
identified as the most important
services in the council's recent budget
consultation Community Safety voluntary
sector grants recycling public
conveniences and street cleaning the
lowest priority areas where residents
wanted to reduce spending were in
communications leisure premises economic
development the rayleigh windmill and
parks and open spaces the budget survey
asking residents to prioritize council
services was published in the last two
editions of Rochford district matters
and made available online on the
council's website copies of the survey
were also distributed at various council
meetings and venues in order to get as
many responses as possible the council
received a total of 377 responses 195 by
post and 182 online the feedback from
this consultation was considered by
members during the budget process
you answered the budget survey or if you
want to help shape and inform policy in
the future why not join our have your
say group this group is made up of
Rochford residents who volunteer to
express their views on the council's
proposals and local services the
information you provide helps the
council to make its decisions in order
for us to get the information we need
you will be asked to fill in
questionnaires and participate in focus
groups when signing up you will be asked
to highlight any particular area of
interest to ensure your views are taken
into account when relevant consultations
come up you can sign up to the group at
www k hy s si GN u P phone Andrew lowing
who is the strategic partnership officer
on 0170 231 8061 or email him at andrew
lowing at Rochford gov UK tips to secure
your home to secure your home against
burglars it's important all year round
essex place is continuing to target
those individuals who are involved in
burglary within our communities however
to help reduce the number of burglaries
Roger District Community Safety
Partnership is encouraging residents to
help protect their homes following these
simple steps always lock all windows
doors and any side gate when you leave
the house even if it's only for a few
minutes make sure your locks are fit for
purpose and conform to british standard
remove all tools ladders and objects
from your garden that could be used to
break in and lock them in a shed or
garage do not assume that even if you
are currently home your house shed
garage side gate or outbuildings will be
safe when unlocked it only takes a
minute for a burglar to enter and take
what is not theirs if you're going out
for the day put a radio on a timer and
set lights on timers to come on when it
starts to get dark always set your a
burglar alarm day and night if you have
one mark your positions with
your house number and postcode using a
UV and permanent marker pen or property
marking system like smart water or
select a DNA protect the rear of your
home fit a padlock or mortise lock to
your side gate heighten your rear fence
or use defensive planting to protect the
rear of your property fit an external
light dusk till dawn style and motion
sensitive security lighting burgers
don't like light remember keys including
car keys should never be left with
insight and easy reach of doors and
windows important valuables including
jewelry and cash should be stored in a
wall or floor safe if possible not in a
jewelry box or in a drawer the first
place a thief will look register any
items that have serial numbers including
games consoles and power tools for free
on the UK property database WWE mobilize
calm if there is a crime in progress or
if immediate response is required dialed
999 for all other queries please phone
101 you can also contact them at ww
Crimestoppers hyphen UK org if you know
something about a crime and do not want
to speak to police you can contact
Crimestoppers anonymously by calling oh
eight hundred five double five one
double one or by filling out an
anonymous online form neighborhood watch
interested in finding a local group and
becoming a member if there is not a
scheme in your area how about setting up
on yourself please contact Rochford and
rayleigh neighborhood watch at email n
HW rayleigh at gmail com website w WR r
NW DC OMG a calm or phone I 1268 bubble
705 19 avoid cold calling scam Essex
Police has issued a warning about a cold
calling scam which is affecting
residents across the county people are
telephoned by fraudsters claiming to be
a police officer or someone from the
bank people are then tricked into
revealing their pin
and handing over their bank card to a
career there are simple steps you can
take to avoid falling victim to this
type of crime do not give out your PIN
number do not give your bank card to a
courier if you suspect you have fallen
victim of fraud or someone has attempted
to defraud you please dial Essex Police
on 101 freecycle tagging with the warmer
weather on its way Railly and Rochford
neighborhood watch team will be
organising a free cycle tagging event
across the district throughout 2014
these events open to all residents of
Rochford district will provide bike
owners with an opportunity to have their
cycles fitted with security tags this
will make identification easier should
they be stolen dates and details of
these events will appear in a future
edition of Rochford district matters and
on the n HW website w WR r NW c om ze
com calling all schools if you would
like to arrange a date for n HW to carry
out cycle tagging in your schools please
contact n HW on 0 1 2 6 h 7 705 19 or
email n HW rayleigh @ gmail.com dance
don't chance bring on the prom the
clocks have sprung forward and summer is
well on its way young people across the
district will be thinking about
celebrating the transitions they are
facing with the biggest events being the
secondary school proms and balls each of
our secondary schools celebrate their
Year Elevens coming to the end of their
GCSE program with an event at the school
the students themselves sometimes want
to make the occasion extra special by
experimenting a little with things they
haven't done before it's a real
opportunity for getting dressed up in a
prom dress or suit and enjoying their
own adult party parents often want to
make it that extra special occasion
arranging memorable transport
and after parties the vast majority of
young people have a great time but there
are occasions where the experimenting
includes alcohol and drugs and if taken
they will reduce inhibitions and
reaction times they also make it harder
to assess risks and cope with them if
you are planning to attend a prom ball
or celebration this summer or your child
is please pick up a stay safe leaflet
from the council offices in rochford or
Civic suite in rayleigh or download a
copy from the website it includes a
range of helpful points to help you
think ahead about travel arrangements
modes of transport looking after each
other risks around alcohol and drugs and
how to avoid being a victim of crime so
you can enjoy yourself without the worry
in our modern and fast-paced society
some individuals find themselves left
behind through no fault of their own
they gradually become more and more
isolated no one to visit no one to call
days can turn into weeks without any
contact with the outside world the
befriending scheme led by the castle
point Association of voluntary services
is an initiative operating within the
castle point and Rochford raley areas to
combat isolation and loneliness the
service helps change the lives of many
residents by pairing them with a trained
volunteer befriender to provide
companionship and support a cup of tea a
walk to the shops or a trip out just
once a week can make a huge difference
to someone's life such has been the
success of the scheme and recognizing
that weekends and evenings can be an
especially lonely time for many people
we have extended the scheme to cover
those periods too since the conception
of a scheme in April 2012 we have
befriended 122 lonely or isolated people
across castle point and Rochford
district to ensure the continued success
of this popular free scheme it is vital
that we have enough volunteers if you
can spare just one hour a week all
expenses paid and would like to make a
real difference to someone else's life
please contact and
fordham on 0 1 2 68 638 for 16 or 07 97
99 1 4 7 43 or by email at an hyphen
Murray Fordham at castle point AVS org
dot uk' if you're aware of anyone you
feel would benefit from a befriender
please ask them to contact their doctors
surgery and they'll refer them through
to Castle Point Association of voluntary
service hi sheriff's mega visit on the
tenth of December chairman counselor
mrs. barbara Wilkins welcome to the High
Sheriff of Essex mrs. Julia Abel Smith
dl her husband Charles Abel Smith and
Andrew Clark grants officer Essex
Community Foundation as she went on a
tour of Rochford and rayleigh following
refreshments at the council offices and
a presentation by the Community Safety
Manager showcasing projects awarded hi
sheriff and Community Safety Partnership
funding mrs. Julia urgle Smith and her
party were taken to mega center Raley
the mega center owned by the charity
active Christian trust received Essex
millennium funding in 2013 to run three
strengthening families programs trustees
Lawrence Kendall and Phil Smith led a
tour of the center which included a
visit to the interactive sensory room
the mega zone lays a game room and mega
play soft play area the morning
concluded with a visit to Rochford town
square and lunch with the chairman
Barbara Wilkins at Ballard's gore
rochford the High Sheriff thanked the
offices of the mega center and Rochford
District Council for the informative and
interesting tour of the district
rochford district matters is designed
and published by Rochford District
Council its editor is Vanessa Conroy the
telephone number for the council is 0 1
702 546 366 the magazine is printed by
Morton print--limited 01 507
five two three four five six this
recording has been produced by
volunteers from rayleigh Rochford and
cass the point talking newspaper in our
modern and fast-paced society some
individuals find themselves left behind
through no fault of their own they
gradually become more and more isolated
no one to visit no one to call days can
turn into weeks without any contact with
the outside world the befriending scheme
led by the castle point Association of
voluntary services is an initiative
operating within the castle point and
Rochford raley areas to combat isolation
and loneliness the service helps change
the lives of many residents by pairing
them with a trained volunteer befriender
to provide companionship and support a
cup of tea a walk to the shops or a trip
out just once a week can make a huge
difference to someone's life such has
been the success of the scheme and
recognizing that weekends and evenings
can be an especially lonely time for
many people we have extended the scheme
to cover those periods too since the
conception of a scheme in April 2012 we
have befriended 122 lonely or isolated
people across castle point and Rochford
district to ensure the continued success
of this popular free scheme it is vital
that we have enough volunteers if you
can spare just one hour a week all
expenses paid and would like to make a
real difference to someone else's life
please contact anne marie fordham on
0126 863 8 for 16 or 07 97 99 1 4 7 43
or by email at an hyphen marie fordham
at Castle Point AVS org UK if you're
aware of anyone you feel would benefit
from a befriender please ask them to
contact their doctors surgery and
they'll refer them through to Castle
Point Association of voluntary service
hi sheriff's mega visit
on the tenth of December chairman
counselor mrs. barbara Wilkins welcome
to the High Sheriff of Essex mrs. Julia
Abel Smith dl her husband Charles Abel
Smith and Andrew Clark grants officer
Essex Community Foundation as she went
on a tour of Rochford and rayleigh
following refreshments at the council
offices and a presentation by the
Community Safety Manager showcasing
projects awarded hi sheriff and
Community Safety Partnership funding
mrs. Julia urgle Smith and her party
were taken to mega center Raley the mega
center owned by the charity active
Christian trust received Essex
millennium funding in 2013 to run three
strengthening families programs trustees
Lawrence Kendall and Phil Smith led a
tour of the center which included a
visit to the interactive sensory room
the mega zone lays a game room and mega
play soft play area the morning
concluded with a visit to Rochford town
square and lunch with the chairman
Barbara Wilkins at Ballard's Gore
Rochford the High Sheriff thanked the
officers of the mega center and Rochford
District Council for the informative and
interesting tour of the district
rochford district matters is designed
and published by rockford district
council its editor is Vanessa Conroy the
telephone number for the council is 0 1
702 546 366 the magazine is printed by
Morton print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6
this recording has been produced by
volunteers from Raley Rochford and
castle point talking newspaper
you